the basic definition of an entity class
is actually pretty bare-bones as we
talked about in the quiz all entities
need a position variable to reference
where it exists in the world this is
going to be used in the future for
things like collision and rendering of
our visibility we'll also need to know
the size of this entity then there's a
couple reasons for this number one it's
important to know the size of the bitmap
that this entity represents 32 pixels 64
pixels but it's also important to know
the size for physics calculations some
objects are bigger than others and
keeping that data around is going to be
important for us later on and finally in
our bare-bones entity class we actually
define an update function this update
function will be called by our larger
game manager class about every frame
allowing any given override identity to
have a time slice in order to do
execution